le département et antenn Réunion vous
présente lien
[Musique]
social chaque année à la Réunion on
dénombre 14000 naissances l'une des
compétences du département est d'assurer
à chaque famille un accès égal à la
prévention et au suivi médical les PMI
les services de protection mat mais les
infantile proposeent différentes actions
allant de la consultation prénatale au
suivi de l'enfant jusqu'à 6 ans nadine a
quatre enfants depuis 5 ans elle se rend
régulièrement à la PMI de son quartier
au
[Musique]
Moufia oh elle est belle celle c'est
quelle étoile c'est ça ah c'est très
joli en période de vacances le salon
familial se transforme en atelier
d'artiste maman regarde ti nadine est
mère de quatre enfants parmi eux Jean et
Mathieu des jumeaux de 5 ans et la
petite dernière Véronique 14 mois la
tortue regarde une joyeuse tribu qu'il
faut divertir mais qu'il faut aussi
garder en bonne santé et dans les
carnets des enfants un tampon revient
souvent celui de la PMI alors la PMI je
l'ai découvert en fait grâce quand
j'étais enceinte de mes jumeaux la la on
déclare la grossesse à la CAF et la CAF
nous envoie un papier de la PMI j'ai
pris contact dès la naissance des et en
effet ils avaient même pas 3 4 jours je
suis allé les peser et les mesurer
depuis nadine est devenue une habituée
vaccination suivi de croissance cette
maman découvre vite les avantages de ce
service de proximité je vais à la PMI
parce qu'en fait chez le médecin souvent
les enfants sont malades alors qu'à la
PMI les enfants ne sont pas malades et
en plus les locaux sont adaptés pour que
les enfants puissent y jouer l'accueil
est très sympa le personnel est est
ouvert ils sont très à notre écoute si
on a besoin de conseils il nous donne
des
conseils tous les de mois Nadine et
Véronique prennent donc la direction de
la PMI du Moufia les consultations se
font le jeudi elles sont gratuites
ouvertes à tous et sans rendez-vous
bonjour vonie
bonjour une consultation classique
commence par un entretien avec la
puéricultrice mon rôle à moi et
d'aborder en fait toutes les
interrogations et les questionnements on
va dire des parents ça pourrait être par
exemple ben l'importance de l'éveil ça
pourrait être le développement
psychomoteur de l'enfant le
développement psychoaffectif
l'alimentation ou tout simplement par
exemple un soutien à l'allaitement
maternel la famille peut ensuite
consulter le médecin de la structure
donc au niveau des vaccins on est à jour
donc le deuxème Priorix entre 16 et 18
mois il s'agit surtout d'assurer les
examens systématique les vaccins ou les
dépistages si les enfants sont malades
Rhin tout fièvre c'est c'est pas nous
qu'il faut consulter c'est le médecin
traitant on est vraiment en parallèle au
médecin traitant nous c'est le suivi
chronique les vaccinations le dépistage
les consultations systématiques tous les
mois les bébés mais par contre on n'est
pas du tout dans l'aigu comment ça se
passe au niveau de l'alimentation bien
mange bien en tout c'est une équipe de
se personnes qui se complète et se relae
dans cette PMI la structure cible aussi
un public fragilisé et les
professionnels peuvent intervenir sur le
terrain on retrouve d'abord les
professionnels ire le médecin de PMI la
sage femme les puricultrices
l'auxiliaire de puricultrice les
éducateurs de jeunes enfants qui non
seulement travaillent à l'intérieur de
la PMI mais peut aussi partir vers les
foyers et les famill nécessiteuses les
familles où il nécessitent un
accompagnement soit sanitaire soit
social soit
psychologique la consultation finie
Nadine et Véronique ne sont pas pressé
de rentrer ici tout le monde les connait
mère et fille viennent aussi
régulièrement les lundis matins le lundi
matin on a mis en place un groupe
d'accueil par enfant et on accueille
tous les parents et enfants de 0 à 3 ans
dans ce lieu alors le lieu est aménagé
et adapté aux enfants on a des petits
coins d'înet des petits coins poupé on
aménage deux salles pour les activités
développer les modes de garde et assurer
le suivi des structures d'accueil c'est
une autre mission des PMI un éventail
d'action qui permet aux services
départementaux d'accompagner au mieux
les familles quelle que soit leur
situation être parent n'est pas toujours
facile c'est pourquoi les centes de PMI
propos aux familles un accompagnement
dans le suivi de la maternité de
l'enfant et un soutien à la parentalité
le département doit toujours être
efficace pour tenter de donner à chacun
un accès à la prévention dès la
naissance apporter des réponses aux
questions donner des conseils sur des
sujets du quotidien comme l'alimentation
le sommeil permet ainsi aux parents de
se sentir rassurés et jouer pleinement
leur
[Musique]
rôle le Service de Protection Maternelle
et Infantile propose des actions de
prévention de dépistage et de suivi à
toutes les mères et leurs enfants de la
grossesse à la naissance jusqu'à l'âge
de 6 ans les PMI réalisent aussi des
actions sur le terrain les PMI sont
composés de personnels compétents et
diversifiés comme des infirmiers des
sagesfemmes des pu ultri des auxiliaires
des éducateurs des médecins les
consultations sont gratuites et sans
rendez-vous pour plus d'informations ou
pour repérer une PMI près de chez vous
rendez-vous sur le site du département
au
[Musique]
www.cg974.fr